welcome everyone to the Sunday puzzlers
paradise class in this class we're going
to do lots of puzzles and today we'll do
a positions from world champion games
[Music]
and in this particular position we have
white playing world champion Alexander
Alekhine world champion number wait
three four correct Arjun Arjun who is
the first three Stein leads Lasker
capablanca and then was Alekhine
Alexander Alekhine so and in this
position he is paying with a white
pieces and he won the game Alexander
Alekhine was a world champion twice okay
1927 to 1935 and also 1937 to 1946 and
let's see if you can play like a lock
line here okay white to play and win
these are not just checkmate positions
these are positions where you have to
come up with the win yes what happen
Arjun you already know it okay take your
time and calculate all the lines okay
and let's give a chance to the audience
here to find it too so what is the idea
here which seems like a big advantage
but how to win it here how to proceed
here now we got our June also ready
let's see
okay calculate what to do you're so
active you have the night you have the
rooks one a seven trunk how to win this
position yeah how to break through okay
let me ask our June
let me ask our June first yes rook takes
g7 our job but that's a sacrificing the
knight takes the knight and now you play
a very neat move Ashish what was your
solution huh
was this your solution Ashish okay one
second what is Ashish saying yes Oh
fancy
very fancy move but what is the threat
that's very nice move because I cannot
take this guy he takes on a fight with a
mate if I take this guy he takes on a
with a mate if I take the night he goes
check and then bill the rook back with a
mate but what are you threatening that's
the thing yeah but okay I'll just move
my bishop I did yeah okay I move the
bishop Adi
I'll go Bishop c4 and I don't think this
is a nice move Ashish good work but it's
not really effective enough okay
yeah we could and we could and we have a
very nice advantage most likely we're
gonna win the game but the answer in the
game is much more stronger because what
our June said was correct takes takes
king g5 in other Knightly the rook is
under attack
show me how black can defend this
location or what can he do with this
rook
so if he moves the rook backwards
what do you do our June check up
checkmate
because the rook is now occupying the
square the king was gonna plan to escape
for no more no more escape there so he
has to play sorry and if he doubles up
the rooks like this check checkmate okay
check and checkmate
what if it what yeah yeah so that's why
it's finally you sacrifice your peace
you go here and you put him in a
position where he cannot do anything
okay
is it clear for everybody how white wins
this position now clear everybody got it
I want to make sure everybody understand
this okay so again once again we proceed
with which move he takes and now it's
there's no way to defend this once you
defend it you're gonna get made it Bobby
you got this all right moving forward
that was world champion Alexander
Alekhine
now after Alec I was a world champion
that is not as known as the others you
know so let me set up the position first
that will give you a time to think about
his name who was the next world champion
after alaka'i world champion number 5 so
k world champion number 5 it was a world
champion briefly for only two years from
1935 to 1937 and his name is Bobby Max
you we and where is it from
Aashish oh yes our job very close
Netherlands Netherlands okay and I
believe he was also feeder president
feeder you know Federation of chess so
he in this game he is playing with a
white pieces okay time see if I can and
his opponent is nest left Nestler
dubrovnik Olympiad 1950 and how did he
proceed here to win this game
effectively it's just a move after which
his opponent reside imagine how strong
finishing touch it was that his opponent
just resigned we will do some positions
of every champion so you know look a
couple of more in order I mean by
looking at it it's pretty clear that
White's position is really really
dominating the question is how to
proceed here okay okay I want to ask
let's see who else Adi
no not yet think think calculate you got
to open up the position Adi how you you
that King is sheltered here it's kind of
tucked in you know tucked in behind the
pawns
so you got to open it up you got to open
it up I do
rook g5i our Jun attacking the knight
the rook so now what can he do here
threat is here and if he goes Nagi 898
what do you do checkmate now he has to
take and very important not to rush here
because it's not too late to spoil this
position would they do a shish clinic a
check he has to go here check
checkmate okay
so rope g5 he takes check mate so and
that's all because of this very strong
pawn what do we call a pawn like this
when we have a strong pawn like this
what is the term we use when the pawn is
on a sixth rank yes wedge pawn wedge
okay and if it block on a third rank
that's pawn which as well on a wedge
wedge pawn all right okay next world
champion after him was me Caillou but
the Nick okay Mikhail Botvinnik and he
won he won a lot a lot of titles okay so
this position is by him okay
block to play and win Mikhail Botvinnik
three times
three-time world champion first time we
want to title 1948 and he was there for
nine years until 1957 how did both
Finnick Windus and his opponent is
Georges both Winnick 1931
well it's not so easy so first move is
very hard move so if your move it looks
very simple look maybe there is
something you're missing even the high
rank players are not raising their hand
they know it's tough one I'm threatening
to take your pawn here you see that the
rook so if you try to go look at you on
which looks natural I just take your
pawn block to play and win black yeah I
can flip the board if you like or you
like it this way
okay
okay any other students maybe want to
raise their hand to try nah see Adi
Bobby come on you guys can do this
Isaac Isaac is raising his head okay
Luke take C to rook F to back and close
yeah I mean C to pawn is your everything
in this position okay C to pawn is very
very strong so what to do to hold that
seat upon that is the question okay you
know and sometimes we have to do
something really sharp really
extraordinary stuff to hold it you know
it's not just any move you play you're
gonna hold it something extraordinary we
need to do and now we got our June Luke
c4 look at that move sacrificing the
rope giving away a full rook now he
takes Bishop c5 peanut he cannot take it
right so he goes here b3 he is pinned
again he moves away he wants to slipped
it away what do you do chucko chucko and
you push the pond now you push me too
and you win the pond
any questions
perfect now if it takes we promote the
pond into a Quinn okay again we start
out with Roxy for takes Bishop c5 be
three takes takes be two ticks I go be
one quick I mean that's a kind of you
know that is very serious move because
you have to really give up your rook to
get these two pawns connect together
okay very very important
all right now I will set up some a
little bit different type of positions
for you okay so I'll be a little bit
this will be more current games okay
games from 2016 white to play and win
this is a game between two strong
grandmas serve allah kitten versus
friedman how did grandmaster valo kitten
win this position playing us white
ashish rook t1 that was excellent
Queeny to before check now I have two
options King edge for King e6 if I go
King e6 trap can go here this cover can
go here can go I have to go here mate
if I go here
checkmate
if he goes here now they should be seven
check my anyway yes sir t1 he is very
very difficult to do anything okay this
is clean before his coming so no it was
very very risky I'm not sure actually
black took some fun something terribly
went wrong wow this is actually no Limpy
it it's yeah something really went
terribly wrong for blocking olympiad
game he has got himself in such a big
trouble here so yeah certainly things
didn't go you don't look good here okay
very good so the movies rook t1 a
natural move it's it's very often you
need to bring the piece into the game to
finish the attack when you have a strong
attack you don't see me that way to win
you see if you can bring more pieces
into the attack okay black to play and
win
Grandmaster Rosenthal ease play this
game Edouard Rosenthal is from Lithuania
how did he win this position there is no
question who is better here but how to
break through what kind of ideas you see
here Bobby
what is your threat but f2 is guarded by
the bishop I mean you're putting
pressure on it right but our addict
Quincy - and he's got the correct answer
sure showed us again the ideas go ahead
rook 83 attacking the Queen
what is the only square the Queen can go
to and now the queen is on inferior
position and we're gonna go for rook
takes c3 look at that now he has to take
it Knight e3 check attacking this and
attacking the Queen
got it winning the Queen and winning the
game as well see how that works you
gotta set it up and then follow it up
okay set it up and follow it up so you
start out with rocketry Queen drops back
to C to rook takes III wonderful tactic
thanks to the strong Knight position on
c4 Tori Eugene Tori Rumble Dini okay it
seems like White has a very nice
advantage but how to break through how
to break through Tori is playing white
against rambaldi [ __ ] master Eugene
Tori the first Grandmaster from
Philippines who is a legend F now how to
break through to the blacks defense it
seems like the Queen is tied up to the
night problems problems problems yeah
are we seeing here what kind of clever
plan he came up with to do it can you do
here what kind of break do you see in
this position okay that will help you
win the game cartoon queen if a Bobby 25
now the point here is guys if I take you
just take back with a knight and you're
winning the policy six because there's
no no b8 option
and I win this win the game so I have to
play Queen b3 no choice Queen c7 now
attacks the night the night cannot be
protected not Queen dat cuz Queen dat
last night f8 when I have six night
effect so it's pinned so he has to go
here check he goes here check he goes
here yeah Bishop e5 check goes on g8 you
take check check and you just basically
take all the pawns that he has okay
you're gonna take all of his pawns and
win the game yeah the point here is we
want to try to get it the Queen active
you know and to take to take advantage
of this this this pin if the King was
that sailing g8 this line wouldn't have
worked the funny thing is it's quite
possible black just played King f7 here
over looking at the Queen a5 instead you
should have played King gauge 7 or
something and then he is you know he's
okay I mean this position is not that
bad but Kegel our server runs into a
very strong tactic Queen here and all
right white to play and win Domingues
versus audubon let's play the spanish
league okay spanish league championship
here Wow very nice idea
three minutes thinking hands down
calculate it's lots of calculation
Ashish gotta calculate like you know
four moves and there are a lot of
interesting sub variations too if you if
you find a main move Bobby
there Bobby Queen f7 is a decent poll
but here's rookie 7 calculate our June
it's deep calculation lots of intricacy
lines okay a lot of tricky lines addict
excellent now if it takes your Bishop f6
mate okay there are a lot of lines to
calculate or takes Bishop f6 mate and if
he goes rookie 7 what's the finishing
line perfect
and that just crushes through takes
Queen f6 mate so he has to play 96 here
96
[Music]
they should takes f6 excellent by the
way there is another winning idea here
rook takes g7
here's to take with the night and then
you play Knight g5 okay so you go Bishop
f6
now I can't take a check so he cannot
take it's made so it has to go here now
rookie 7 which he did know what am I
saying
Bishop f 8 96 yeah Bishop Bishop I said
and now the final idea that you need to
find okay
Archer
better
it's you know you got to continue with a
tactical idea here
Adi how'd you find night xg5 you don't
want that night to take you you know
that's the main thing a really really
brutal finish here
Ashish yes
rook takes g7 look at that now if takes
the night then what's the finish and
unstoppable mate on age seven
so yes take back with the bishop Knight
g5 now he cannot take 95 because you
have a mate on g7 and if he goes here
you have a mate on h7 so it has to go
here what do you do then and now which
the last guy who says I want to be in a
game as well you know I want to be a
participant right
you always bring everybody into the game
okay and now if he takes look at six
mate
and if he takes here Queens yourself
checkmate let's do this again so
everybody can see how it happens so it
started with Queen h6 right guys clinic
696 is bad - we have Luke g6 if he takes
you have a mate on f6 immediately so it
has to go here now Bishop takes f6 by
the way rook g7 is a nice finish - I
just made on itself so if it dropped g7
sorry Bishop f6 he goes here rook g7 95
feet on h7 meat on its own okay
yeah this is very nice King Bishop f6
Queen d7 mate
95 Queen g7 mate and if it goes King g8
check and always bring the last piece
into the game okay and that's the game
over alright thank you everybody for
joining this class and happy New Year to
everybody to our listeners you know and
we'll be back again after New Year's
with new videos as well okay see you
guys next week okay
[Music]